et beaucoup de gens disent que ce
mouvement demain du 17 novembre est
récupéré par l'extrême droite
florian philippot qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça parce que ça c'est des
choses qu'on a beaucoup vu sur twitter
moi je ne suis absolument pas d'extrême
droite je pense que vous êtes vous alors
maintenant non mais je me bats les
extrêmes d'ici mes notes alors
[Applaudissements]
non mais moi je combats c'est un peu
ringard outre le rassemblement national
et je veux plus la souche ou plus à
droite chevènementiste je suis considère
qu'il faut prendre dans mes bras sont le
26 à vous laisser où il a dit que moi je
les quitte et d'ouverture de la gauche
bah je suis voulez oui sur son poids n'a
aucune importance mois jusqu'à ce coup
droit je peux faire tranquille je pense
que ce crime
il ya surtout des gens qui viennent de
la gauche et des accords viennent chez
nous du parti communiste la france a
soumises du rassemblement national des
républicains du ps pour florian
philippot que je suis non mais non
seulement je suis pas mais je le combats
moi je n'aime pas les extrêmes sur ce
que ça sert à rien le jet marine mais on
a eu quelques désagréments dit si vous
n'êtes plus d'extrême droite voulait
venir manger des boulettes
[Applaudissements]
juste un point sur le fond beaucoup plus
intéressant sinon moi je veux être dans
l'écologie sauver la planète et paraître
dans ce mouvement
et ben moi aussi je me souviens pas être
dans l'écologie je pense que c'est voilà
c'est une facilité du gouvernement c'est
une astuce de com du gouvernement de
dire ceux qui sont pour la base la
baisse des taxes des carburants qui
seront demain dans la rue avec leur
gilet jaune sont des anti écolos sont
des brûlures
ça c'est bidon voilà parce que ce
gouvernement s'il veut être écolo s'il
veut être écolo qu'il arrête de faire
venir les containers entiers qui
viennent de chine qui polluent
infiniment plus soudé tanker des super
temps car vous savez qu un supertanker
les gros bateaux là c'est l'équivalent
de pollution d'un million de voitures un
million bannir les armes on les
multiplie vont parce qu'on n'arrête pas
de signer des accords de libre échange
ont fait venir des produits les produits
sur les chirurgiens de chine etc alors
tout ça tout ça ça c'est un système
mondialisé hyper pollueurs voyez moi je
suis dit fais moi solo je suis hyper
écolo parce que moi je vais relocaliser
jeu de la proximité et de la qualité
ça se fera pas avec votre modèle
ultralibéral et passera pas juste avec
nous les rangs du chalet sera localement
sur l'extrême droite jusque là les gens
qui sont le plus touchés par les hausses
de taxes c'est plutôt des gens qui
habitent dans la france périphérique où
le vote national est sur représentée
mais là où le front national fait ses
meilleurs scores et c'est quand même pas
osé faisait d'un côté oui
d'un côté le rassemblement national et
de l'autre côté les patriotes essayent
de profiter de l'aubaine tout ce que
l'on sait déjà qu'ils sont aussi son
souffrance mais c'est vrai et ils votent
pour qu'ils veulent mais non mais moi je
les critiques ça il se leva le dessin
plaisant peuvent plus il n'aura même
plus les gens mais moi je suis je les
comprends simplement la tentative de
récupération et ne me paraît pas voilà
on peut prendre dans la récupération ça
veut dire par exemple je suis d'accord
le ps ou wauquiez ça me paraît un peu
bizarre il est à peu près l'inversé air
où ils ont fait inverse aujourd'hui sont
complètement juridique alors moi j'ai
pas changé dopé de lisier tout allait
alors